so here's my thing with Yuzu I think
it's great it's got an amazing flavor
but you put it in anything you cannot
taste anything else except for Yuzu it
[ __ ] takes over everything and you
can't deny this it does well what's
wrong with that when it tastes good
because like some dishes they're like
it's it's usually hint of Yuzu and
you're like all right you taste it
you're like I just tasted YouTube and
it's like I don't want people to stop
putting Yuzu in everything because it as
a dominant flavor it [ __ ] sucks like
as a standalone it it doesn't suck as a
dominant flavor I [ __ ] I [ __ ] love
using I will fight to the death every
YouTube drink is like it's like like so
when you get like uh sometimes you get
like a little like sprinkle a little
user in it and then it's like now all I
can take is use it and the same with
food they sprinkle a bit of Yuzu on it
and all I can taste is Yuzu and I'm like
I'm so juicy why it's like bacon on the
burgers you bite into a burger with a
bacon in it and it just tastes like
bacon so yusu is not as potential
what are you on but like it's got such a
unique like it's got such a unique
flavor no I agree that's what I love
about it there's not many things in the
world that you know I don't want to take
that tastes like YouTube because like
the thing about Yuzu ponzu is oh my Lord
oh like the thing about Yuzu is that it
it always tastes like Yuzu
flavor to the audience I don't even know
it's it's like the only way I can
describe someone described it to me once
as eating a lemon and an orange together
but like even then it's like it's hard
like that's probably the closest but
like it feels like a vinegary lemon
vinegar is way more overpowering no like
if you added a dash of vinegar to Lemon
that's how I would imagine it's kind of
like a very like bitter-ish kind of uh
line okay how would you describe limes
then
more tasteful lemon
but the lemon with a bit of it that's
but that's why like that's why Yuzu is
just so [ __ ] good because it has such
a Google how does Google describe such a
distinct flavor profile in terms like
the citrus fruits because like you know
you take you take let's say a lemon and
a lime and yes there is a difference in
flavor but it's not massive you know
yeah you know I'm sure a lot of people
wouldn't even be able to taste the
difference between a lemon and a lime
you know uh same thing would say you
know orange and tangerines or
clementines there is a there is a
difference you know in the in their
flavor profiles but it's not massive
yeah and I feel like Yuzu has such a
distinct nothing else tastes like music
yeah nothing else tastes like Yuzu and
it tastes I mean subjective how amazing
it tastes so everyone seems to agree
that it's a hybrid of uh either lemon
lime and a bit of grapefruit which I
would kind of say oh yeah yeah
it's got the good properties of
grapefruit without the law yeah
afterwards
grapefruit is the worst citrus fruit it
is okay I will agree on that I kind of
like grapefruit
I used to hate it would you okay
grapefruit is the one citrus fruit you
just cannot have by yourself oh no no I
can't have a bite so that that that's
cheating that makes it an awful [ __ ]
citrus fruit because if you need
something else we gotta have lemon juice
by itself I can it's actually like you
know no doubt without any thinners 100
lemon juice
if I got a full-on lemon right now cut
it in half squeeze all of it bone dry
into a glass and gave it to you would
you be able to finish yo I only have my
lemon butter
if you if you gave it to me all in the
glass I would prefer the lemon juice
over the grape juice
yeah I would prefer it really yeah but
yes I would I would I mean I think
grapefruit is like every worst citrus
fruit flavor profile just in one and the
only thing that offsets that is having
like some sugar or something with it but
do you like better things
yeah yeah a lot of bit of things so then
why don't you like grapefruit
it's just no because it's like it's just
it's bitter doesn't mean that we're
gonna like it yeah it also just tastes
bad and then it's bitter like it just
tastes better and I'm not saying it's
the best tasting fruit in the world
I'm saying it's the worst tasting food
really it's one of them it's definitely
it's definitely down there
okay well durians is in no during
[ __ ] slab Stars that's that's just in
the carry but I don't even count that as
fruit that's just like that's just it is
literally called the king of fur
something went wrong with it look it up
who called it that it's everyone calls
it that no everyone is wrong well you
you can wear your crown of durians if
you want because I I ain't wearing my
crowns a rotting dead corpse on a plane
and a durian airport security would ask
me to throw away the jury yeah
it's equivalent I don't see shine saying
a dead body as as someone who's been in
Thailand I've been to stores I don't
know if I've told this story on the
podcast maybe I have but I'll repeat it
just in case I've seen Thailand's like
I've been to places in Thailand I've
seen stores and places that have a sign
that says you are not allowed to bring
guns in this place and also along with
guns no durian so in in some places in
Thailand guns are in the same level as
durian somehow I could get that I can
get that I mean it tastes good but it
definitely smells like [ __ ] that's for
sure like until it touches your tongue
you just your brain is just like am I
eating a turd right now and then the
moment it touches your tongue you're
like okay it's not what to do it yeah
this is this is this is why I will never
be truly seen as divide yeah
this is the real reason
I thought he doesn't like durian that's
the real reason why they don't see me as
one of them you're a great big felony
it's like oh you can speak our language
you do but can you eat durian yeah it's
like it's like an undercover cop who
just refuses to try drugs you know it's
like oh oh you're clearly a pig of
course of course you're not one of us oh
my God one thing that surprises me is
that I'm calling it out Yuzu is going to
be the next big fat I'm surprised it's
still not yet I'm surprised as well it's
it's because this because this is in
America in California you know yeah this
like if this if if there's a fruit that
screams privileged California it's using
yo get it's like it's going to be the
next [ __ ] Starbucks infused flavor I
swear to God I'm like oh you can see
yeah use Duty in California using cold
tea honestly that's really [ __ ] good
you know what's a mid flavor and it is
just like not good sorry yeah
Sakura just doesn't taste good like you
can't change I don't know anyone who
actually thinks Sakura is an amazing
flavor right they just love the theming
that's it everyone just it just looks
good I was like oh cherry blossoms oh
yeah Sakura doesn't taste like and then
you drink the [ __ ] the Frappuccino or
some [ __ ] from Starbucks you're like
just use a [ __ ] actual flavor yeah
wait we're talking like Sakura flavored
or like ume flavored uh Sakura flavor
right do you like ume flavored stuff
UMES like Plum I I mean I love umeshu
Yeah and everything else we made is kind
of me well the thing about Sakura is
that the trees just Market to themselves
perfectly they're just like we're gonna
Bloom for like one time in the year and
you've only got a few [ __ ] days
there's your scarcity guys all right
scarcity yeah scarcity scarcity
soccer is literally the hype Beast of
flowers
[Applause]
that's literally hard on me
a drop of flowers
[Laughter]
yeah but is there a reason why we
haven't genetically modified the sakura
tree to grow all year round or have we
scarcity man it's all marketing
marketing I know I'm sure they could I'm
sure they could I don't know I think I
think maybe it's because Japanese the
Japanese probably see it like
historically they probably see it as
like uh the the scarcity is like a very
like Poetic thing yeah you know because
like it's it's been like that for sure
poetic [ __ ] thousand yeah it's like
oh you know it's beautiful it's like
it's like a firework it's only momentary
but while it's there it is the most
beautiful thing of the planet is there
any uh sakura trees that have been
genetically modified to bloom all year
round car can you well I know I know for
a fact that all Sakura trees in Japan
are all clones of each other like as in
as in the trees and that's why they all
bloom all at the same time sure yes I'm
100 telling me that there is an alpha
Sacramento
they literally all share the same brain
surely now maybe they're descendants
they all can't be the same otherwise
like one past would kill them all well
yeah is that really true I'm fairly
certain and that's that's the reason
though why they all bloom all at the
same time and then they all fall all at
the same time as well give us an answer
to do it all year round but then being
able to do it again important oh so they
have been trying
because they've been trying so they can
do it to bloom in Autumn I actually
would be sick are you kidding I would
not want to go Hannah me in Autumn why
not oh sorry Autumn I thought you said
August oh yeah I was like August
could you imagine what the it's all like
you know really red and yellow and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] do that okay yeah I'm sure
like I'll be I I I'd laugh if there's
like a sakura tree committee that just
goes around like [ __ ] breaking every
science project that tries to attempt
that seems very on brand for you oh no
no if Japan is full of one thing it's
Puritans yeah
the dream it's like and then there's a
minute but it's pretty yeah but more
Socrates and then people will realize
that Sakura tasting stuff and then
Starbucks comes around the corners like
that'll make some dough again baby let's
go do a fact check on the old cherry
blossoms are the same yeah all cherry
blossoms are the same
they're all replicated yeah but that's
yeah I I remember I saw that on like a
bunch of different Japanese sites so I I
know that for certain and like TV and
stuff I don't know how they did it but
makes sense